but chugged iced coffee sorry I thought
you were ready hi everyone we're coming
at you a day early I'm not ready it's a
day early as if you watch less episode
you know we wanted to avoid III madness
tomorrow if you're watching this then
tomorrow EA's conference what will be
going on you should watch that I'll be
over on Twitch GameSpot will be
streaming and I'll be hosting with Lucy
games Lucy James help helps every all
parties you did these backwards oops you
try to make fun of me and then you just
made yourself my key party face it was
what two years ago yeah when you still
worked here yes it's been a while before
you were merely a cameo did I ever
really work here so what happened last
time we reunion let's remember Chris
right I lost all my [ __ ] no no you got
you got it back um you're right but what
I'm saying is later Mike's don't realize
we were really I'm so loud what I was
saying was is I lost all my [ __ ] last
episode because I became Chris Redfield
yeah I'm no longer a woman but you have
all the item boxes left but we found a
box right before we ended oh no I
remember what's happened is an axe
remember you tried go in the knife run
against the worm yeah like a worm so I
would say bring these alright didn't do
too terribly but he did die but I think
I was wearing it down yeah if you're
binge watching this show then you
probably just watched that it's time for
revenge
if you've waited an entire week it's
time for revenge it's worth not an
entire week six days dead so this thing
this is resident Knievel by the way I
never know if I should introduce the
show I think that most people know by
now what did I would like to think that
you don't have to but I would like to
think that if you're hanging out
watching this you've seen once before if
you knew this is like the I'm curious
which episode this is leo she started
subscribing to GameSpot
you know what I actually almost did a
statistical like overview of it well we
faithful YouTube comments or I can pull
that up I think we have a hundred videos
and before I forget actually I'm gonna
go back to our camera and I promised we
would show fan art last time yeah
actually no let me get it all ready well
thank ya I will forget so like why don't
I kill the worm and then we'll do it you
keep playing while I go back and come
across it because it might take a while
a lot of people tweeted me so I have to
go pretty far back run but yeah so I
guess assault rifle might be your best
bet on this I feel like I liked women
Eric tase Twitter profile
where is it sorry sometimes it's hurt
[ __ ] that wasn't what I intended
do you think I hit it I think purple
stuff comes out yeah I gotta stop
standing there I don't watch this I've
got to go back like a week for this
stuff it's really hard for me to know
the best place to stand
I was just going I'm not really paying
attention at the moment it's going great
oh yeah no I'm dying a lot yeah you're
in it yeah but I'm getting hit yeah I'm
just like aimlessly shooting into the
void here
that's good I think so did you bring any
health items yes I'm seeing a gift
someone made of you getting knocked off
a helipad oh my god that was so funny it
was from her I was so disappointed and
her crease the county pro the county I
Pro on got you you [ __ ] oh he's got me
too it could be better I'll tell you
that getting closer
like am i shooting it like where are we
gotcha I like this area feels full I
feel like I can run
hi one more bullet didn't really I gonna
have to pay attention you just did it Oh
oh yeah forgot run yeah yeah it was a
guy in there that's one of the pitfalls
of playing a week apart holy [ __ ] turd
and then he shoot him wasn't it also
that you need to remember how you would
show this monitor yeah so I'm gonna bomb
all we have to do is switch the HDMI I
believe the one that's plugged into our
ps4 to this monitor but we can do that
later on I'm just pulling this up so I
remember at the end of episode 2 show
this stuff I don't think it is that easy
really I thought that was your
suggestion how would you see it though
is that token thanks for said point
[Music]
we need to put it in a splitter oh wait
hon I could try a little experiment oh I
got my lighter sweet
there's no yeah that's game two I think
you want to put it on that okay well
either way we'll keep playing and I'll
eat I'll like message but if you can
email your yeah so we can see your email
it's dead now
I missed this cutscene because yeah
because what cuz we were like planning
out how we were gonna do this okay so I
got a handgun bullet wares from and I
got some bogan arrows and I'm full [ __ ]
um will I discuss the worm at all I do
not know what do you mean how am I on
healthcare oh there's Chrome I like the
idea of me like playing this game while
you technically try to fix something
yeah it's all fine over here mm-hmm just
grow back like a couple weeks just keep
like I asked you last time but what's it
like to be reunited with Chris that's
what I meant to say that reunion feels
good feel like he I don't know I
actually kind of liked playing it's
clear she feels a bit honest and humble
he's a bit macho but he does his job
mm-hmm it's hard to argue um I wonder if
I should just eat an herb cuz I'm on
orange what do you think yeah that's a
blue one but I do not poisoned so I
think I'm gonna get a great deal of a
couple first aids right or did you bring
them all to the fight no I have a lot I
don't have um I think I'm doing fairly
good here but like I wonder if I play
again as clear that would be nice I
wonder from getting a blue because I'm
going to get poison soon I don't know oh
yeah you know what I don't have a lot of
health I have two Health's and I have
another I'm actually sorry I keep
changing my mind I'm gonna should I use
this because it's at 7% and just chuck
it
I don't see I don't know I don't know if
there's a possible way you can refill it
later I highly doubt it it just makes me
want to kind of use it up I know you
mean but I it takes up time I would
store it for now all right if you come
across something else then that's what
I'll do doesn't pull it back out you got
it it sounded weird
well I only to you loading seems to be
taking a while try again Twitter there
you go all right so wait where did I go
wrong okay here we go he's dead oh the
worm is gone do you think it's under he
killed it oh it was like lying on the
ground before you mean yeah
all right we're getting closer yeah I'll
just like you should get all of them
I will you should save them just to the
driver so I'm just gonna pull them onto
the desktop here and then email them the
old-fashioned way the old-fashioned way
they're all from like regular Knievel
viewers so you can afford them to me
like our grandparents do be like BCC you
top ten Knievel images okay Oh forgot
since last episode Roseanne's show got
cancelled sure dad
is that what's in the no that's just I'm
just going so far back there my
notifications to find these people seem
to be really excited for a dying light
potential sequel during dynamite was a
great game yeah
it's absolutely something I would most
like and I think it did well right like
it was financially successful so they're
still supporting it with the new battle
royale mode so I was thinking that
battle royale mode is hood a chant
attempt to get people interested in
again after they did the DLC two years
ago which was really good the following
was like better than the base game or a
like it was really good
supplemental thing here we go
get up copy you link
Rep Eric tase got a sign out of his Oh
Oh balls I don't think that hurts you I
think we're just gonna automatic we
definitely bit me bites your hanky he
just three step authentication CBS makes
us do we have that to most people now
like you have to like have your phone
buzz you in
it's the whole thing god help me if I
ever lose my phone I actually don't
think I'd be able to like get any work
done I thought there was another one I
guess I killed all of them good job Mary
oh that's interesting can I pull this
box key jump on the barrel now no it's
just interesting that I can jump on that
box though isn't it
mm-hmm it's weird
seems to be under maintenance and then
this door is hidden by a barrel so can't
do that so I guess we'll go out here I
don't think there's much to say of that
room I went on a rant maybe not a rant
yesterday uh-huh just got annoyed with
all this [ __ ] you see the actor she
played Rose in Star Wars like deleted
all her Instagram stuff I did see that
she was getting a lot of yeah apparently
it was like a lot of the Star Wars fan
base I have to I'm not sure where the
source came from but I went in this like
annoying thing like if you're like
consider yourself a fan of something and
then that leads you to be that much of
an [ __ ] you should re-examine what it
means to be a fan yeah I agree
fan has such a negative connotation
lately and it it shouldn't because or at
least in my mind it does and it
shouldn't because like phantom used to
be great for like people who share a
common interest and like want to find a
group of friends that way but like when
it gets to the point where you're like
harassing someone because you want to
defend your supposedly defend this
property that you are so insecure about
yeah [ __ ] off yeah I didn't like the
last chat I had I'm not kind of
another's to people and then there's the
people that say like yeah it wasn't her
fault of the movie sucks they shouldn't
be harassing her like you shouldn't be
harassing anybody because the movie
sucks yeah it sounds like you have two
arguments then which is basically like
harassment is [ __ ] disgusting in any
situation yeah and stop like liking
something so much that you feel like you
have ownership of it yeah I agree but
like I want on this thing about like how
the word fan has become such a negative
has taken on such a negative connotation
my mind and it shouldn't but that's
where I'm at in my worldview and I wish
it wasn't the fact I came from theirs
don't remember I'm just gonna check a
couple doors here cuz I got lost I do
that a lot
okay it was the opposite so it came from
here I also like she's such a little
sweetie pie and she's so stoked to be
there and she like seems like such a
nice lady I just think people should
[ __ ] off
like it's okay if people like things I
don't like almost any of the new Star
Wars and like I don't care if you like
them that's cool I think that's awesome
Rob watches them like ten times a piece
so does Josh aw I went and saw them with
them even though it's like not a big
deal to me because they like them why
can't people like things you know what I
mean like they hurt me that they like
that stuff people people who say it's
like a sjw like extreme left approach to
defend against harassment no I'm just
defending against [ __ ] like there's
no politics to it just stop being an
[ __ ] to people I don't care whether
you're right left middle if you're a fan
of Knievel and I used fan there on
purpose can evil fan their dope for them
I don't think you have any like I don't
think we have any caustic fans you guys
Rock glad that you don't [ __ ] harass
people because if you do then I would
tell you to stop watching our show but
you don't because you're awesome there's
no reason to like I don't like Mary I
don't like your social media yeah okay
so ie sorry tangent I'm glad you kept
the game going cuz I've kind of been
focusing yeah I wanna show so I want to
show this stuff off and I forgot last
time I felt awful because these people
well they reminded you funny stuff but
like I want to show people were doodling
during the episode and okay so I send it
to my personal emails so worst case if
we can't figure out the HDMI thing at
the on the episode I'll just hold my
phone up to the camera I think
this computer is on if that computers on
we'll be fine I think I have to sign in
but to switch the HDMI yeah yeah but
whatever you put on here is gonna be on
the stream like here so we'll just wait
until oh I see what you're saying okay
I'll go to our camera got it and then
while you're doing it I'll wait until
you have the pictures up yep while I'm
on our camera alright of course I can I
think we can figure it out but why don't
you tell me what we're doing in this
game now yeah I'm I don't know what's
going on you killed the worm that's good
I came down found a new save room it
looks like I found a new save grenades
in that locker
there's grenades in that locker did you
see those before I told you that yes I
see everything there's a blue garden
down bottom right it looks like
something out of some poison enemies
coming up yeah looks like a map of was
that a map of Antarctica there was no
there's far too much green on it I
haven't saved but I got a new save room
and I was gonna ask you if you think
that it's something interesting
little-known fact you know Antarctica is
one of the most lush continents on the
planet like the density of rainforests
is equivalent almost equivalent to that
of the Amazon River Basin
I hope people know well enough not to
base their geography or any knowledge on
you any well I know some oh the battery
pack so I passed that earlier wonder
what that's gonna be for alright so you
need a helper crunch that looks like a
poison spider um I feel like I should
dodge it meat you're not really ready to
a dodge it it's kind of bad yes oh oh
wait there's another one is that two or
the same one I don't know God do laundry
tonight at least it was cold coffee
still stains God well cuz that that that
like the actual camera angle changed to
spiders or something
[ __ ] man sorry for your headphones
wait when did this happen
sorry what was that this thing is the
thing so puzzle now gun again
blue left wait what is that blue red
green brown Oh gotcha
I just try to understand the puzzle was
figuring out what those letters
represent okay we've got it
it was colors look around the room maybe
blue red green brown the map has blue
red green and brown oh right there
cool okay so long so red green lava
burns forests flows to see blue so red
blue red green blue brown okay assuming
earth is brown yes red well sorry it
wasn't red you okay red green
I don't know whether you know we're
trying to help a bot oh you did it
oh is that gun oh I wonder if it's do it
to again why'd you give me that look I'm
actually confused because I knew well
you told me to help
[Laughter]
fine I'll shut up so it's only a replica
it doesn't work okay just a minute or
should I put it back for now no clue
yeah I hate back I am going to take out
this gun and kill those spiders because
I hate them don't tell me not to okay
that's just how I feel okay should I say
ever no no I don't want to do it was did
you confirm there are two spiders so
that was the same one I am unaware of
like anything yeah we know that yourself
where is it he's coming oh my god
shut god damn it Walt
no not miss Dodge oh god it's out
handgun now I guess oh did you see that
sick ass Dodge
I think the spider just sucks that's the
take away from your jumps I can't see
execution do I think I'm shooting it I
feel like this is a waste yeah figures
it's hard to know like what if it's on
the ceiling like okay there you go nice
don't aim down you're not hitting it oh
he's dead yeah I know I just [ __ ] got
poisoned did you are you positive
there's just no doubt yeah you're done
nice
[Music]
you took a photo of me playing the game
yeah that's rude what do you mean that's
would you do it all the time to tell
people we're recording oh well yeah but
I'm in like serious mode can't even see
your face
I'm like this so when people see this
now they'll think ahead a couple days
I'm gonna be like like time-traveling
stressed out I [ __ ] hate spiders
spiders don't bother me as much as
snakes know about snakes I know about so
I'm on caution but I'm not poisoned
okay I'm not nice so because I'm an
orange
I think either I should combine two
greens or I should just use a first-aid
spray thoughts and you're not poisoned
I'm not poisoned but I'm on orange and I
don't want to die but I could always
just use a green and continue to survive
here so I'm still pretty unclear on the
advantage of combining two greens over
just using a first-aid spray I don't
know I think a first dates braid does
better I think if you're on orange a
first day it's very useful because then
you have more greens yeah I agree
then again I've been wrong before
Oh what oh my god the amount of times
you're wrong all right so
I'm gonna use this first-aid spray I'm
going to put that battery in the battery
hole nice you know as people who like
work on cars say your battery holes
empty should be a mechanical be a grease
monkey yeah you know I don't care about
that term watch Seinfeld mm-hmm man
that's a putty what he says hey you know
I feel about that term grease monkey
yeah hey what did I say about that work
the Seinfeld fans will appreciate that
impression it's actually not bad yeah I
totally believe in God all right you're
going to help if they do the voices um
Kronk Joe yeah the neighbor in the
wheelchair and Family Guy Krong New
Groove is that him same voice oh yeah um
for some reason I was thinking a captain
from work
Bob Bob's Burgers
no I don't want you to jump up on their
dum-dum no no no that's it that's the
dude that does Archer isn't it I don't
know he's also voiced McGee so we it's
blue oh okay
I was like why did I get up on here yes
that's convenient that the that fits
perfectly into the broken catwalk
have you been here before this looks
familiar doesn't know you were here
before I remember this is the room where
you couldn't really do anything as
Claire I actually do think as well that
we said why do we still have this broke
like why are we like why's this place
even exist anymore if it doesn't have
like a I was like a hole in it now we
know mm-hmm although we plan to utilize
and enhanced anti decay alloy called
deployed to create the storage capsule
we've had to cancel
to fact it's excellent resistance to all
kind of liquid including acid it easily
dissolves when soaked with a mixture of
the two chemicals Clemens a and Clemente
Sigma said of Sigma
I'm gonna go with funky e due to the
lethal nature of the new Bo W we cannot
be too careful in choosing the material
in their storage capsule we have instead
decided to use deployed to create the
plate portion of the Eagle plate which
shines in indigo blue
man this is some dense reading hope
nobody finds out
the a type used for gun maintenance and
possesses no conspicuous characteristics
however funky II will change its color
to blue at a certain temperature
it's an odd coincidence that the
temperature is exactly the same as the
date of completion of this training
facility based on our analysis of funky
e we believe that Clement possesses more
features and as new information is
learned we will update the file riveting
yeah there was a lot of technical
mumbo-jumbo in there but I do think
think we learned a couple important
pieces that we don't want to like forget
this today Wednesday dammit
oh right the lady
[Music]
I thought she was nude oh I thought they
were the same person
oh yes yeah well she came out of the
tube when he died but she was dead Chris
I'm sending some company to keep you
entertained
it's a Roomba little does he know I want
one of those I wonder how much time I
have this was the room of the grenades
and [ __ ] I don't think this game has
like a persistent boss I could be wrong
but I'm very 85% sure uh-huh
well if it does or does it know what I'm
doing in here like why did I come in
here there's like nothing it's all dead
maybe it's just in case you need it
did you come this way yet no oh this is
the upstairs hallway now you're near the
safe room that's like an elevator right
or whatever we don't need basement do
that yet I don't so I came from here
yeah came from there which means there's
this door that's the safe room this
direction is the hallway
[Music]
whoa this place changed oh there's
Albert sweet sweet sweet sweet sweet
sweet down we go
Oh Lord what is that it isn't the safe
room in here
I believe so straight ahead yeah
well should we go just yeah go for it
just jump off the waterfall uh-huh
uh-huh I actually almost out of bullets
I mean I'm okay but I can't kill a
thingy I don't know okay
jump maybe you didn't the elevator then
jump down to the basement Oh remember
there was running water in the basement
maybe that's connected it must be well
should I go into the save room area
light it over here just to see if it
still exists
sure okay to see what you can see see
what I can see I saw Jim Carrey
so Oh Lord
these dudes in their Confederate
uniforms like [ __ ] I don't have a lot of
bullets
for these guys
go back to knifing their legs that's a
good idea you're confident that I feel
really good about this I'm gonna get
twice that stumble we fire extinction
okay I did a bad job I got a little bit
Oh Sheamus good okay the fire yeah
oh this is the what did you get in this
room this is where you got the crossbow
I think this is that lab up there where
you got the painting in the next room
and the crossbow here see if something
is back also there's something on the
desk next to you okay there's a lot
going on you dropped yes I will take
those and I will take this desk for the
camera
right there on the rubble oh I see
whoo nice going saddlebags okay
seems the same was this always this big
no you got four ten slots now you won't
you used to have a man who might argue
actually don't remember I just okay
that's broken so you can go down those
stairs yeah hopefully
where's over here oh there's a door to
your right it's too dark it's like a
towel rack
I don't want anyone to know this but
I'll have a lot of bullets
just pretend just point the gun exam B's
pretend your bullets that'll scare them
like honestly I don't have enough
bullets to kill that thing whatever it
is I don't think I can go through here I
need the fire extinguisher yeah I think
the elevators your only route right now
the fire extinguishers on the other side
of that door is the only problem in the
metal detectors we're before the metal
detector yeah I don't know how to get to
it anymore you have to get outside if
you can seems as if yeah you have to
take the elevator which hopefully leads
you to get outside again that would be
great
it's this way it's this way
three came from I thought it is but
that's where the elevator I think you
got the chem storage key fire
extinguisher or use the campus large key
either one
there's no it's right here I'm dumb you
think that would shut down an event on
the fire were this building structurally
safe there's like never one or try one
first work your way down
I don't maybe I should have gone back
upstairs and gotten like that bow-gun
cuz I [ __ ] have no like defense right
now like I'm in a bad spot knifeless
ass okay
[ __ ] this is bad this is bad
this isn't good that was bad you got 13
bullets hopefully you come across it
more soon well Mike look do I think you
can knife I'm if you're got time is
better no they both bit me yeah but
you're because he timed it poorly I'm
both yeah there you go
hey he's got to get that first one
really far away so the second one drops
him oh nice doing the work hard stay
down
how hurt did I get that was not probably
worth it you saved ammo you can reload
your gun when you get the chance yes
good idea save space that's this is all
my bullets
I hope there's not a [ __ ] trying to
member what boss fight Oh
anything he can get in here now oh yeah
I remember those there's a hole to put
something in did she ever do that
no oh is that the battery no no I
already use the battery just kidding
would you use the battery on actually oh
in the room where the trigger the the
chair that filled the hole I already did
this room yeah
now if I had a save a puck then I could
save but I don't so I can't
yeah
other Daugherty right in you guess
basement it's like got hurt for no
reason I think you'll have to come back
they're trying to go why there's got to
be a hole there was a hole in the
diorama there's a hole in the diorama
you're in the diorama girl oh my god
she's got diorama d hey Bri huh
whew that's a good sign
what the song no oh that thing's down
the stairs are down this time yes they
were not before before you go down here
I went down there what's on the wall
right there I don't know if have room
for this leave it on the wall for now no
I'll take you take it where's comes the
worst you've got the fence
oh okay so you can only use that shotgun
down here it appears why there's handgun
ammo down here - wait oh don't pick
those I'm not yeah oh [ __ ]
I didn't mean I didn't mean to do you
mind you're gonna get rid of shotgun
briefly but definitely get that do you
think I should equip the shotty idea
yeah I would take check out that room
before you put it back on the wall
please be a safe room I'm a little
anxious that I like haven't saved in a
while and I I'm not very healthy here
but a heartbeat or something okay those
look like they've got attack of
predators in them they sure do
I don't like this I'm not well and I
don't have any oh I good I got one heal
it's not a lot though and an antidote
that's like this is all new please give
me should I not take it I'm full now I
should have taken those the goddamn ink
ribbons so if I get like a key or
something I can't you just go put the
shotgun back on track that's true
although the fact that you can only use
it down here leads me to believe unless
you find a fake shotgun down here or
something god it's cameras terrible
wait I wouldn't push that yet that's
gonna open the capsules just what's down
this way first or the door
can you would you agree we don't want to
open those capsules yet I don't think I
don't know there's stuff on the ground
I don't know that electricity I don't
know where the electricity is I can't
take this it is that doorknob or I
wonder if that's the thing you put in
the diorama I regret taking those ink
ribbons you climb on top of those wait
yes
or maybe you have to push that she'll
where there's something on top of those
two second from the left so I was
wondering if you could
shotgun shells maybe can you get between
the two wooden boxes and push those
toward the barrel if I can I don't see
how god damn this camera angles so bad
he used climbed straight up those two
boxes by any chance
I doubt it this one yeah you want me put
more let me push can I jump this is the
coolest thing I can do yeah I don't know
and I can't pick up there's this red
button over here ominous bouton chem
Sarge keyhole
you have in here matauri oh yeah maybe I
don't know if that's count sorry dammit
I mean it was a real good thought all
right feel a bit stuck there's that's
where it came from right
yeah nice [ __ ] I can't take that ya know
that you already have 13 so that won't
take up more space
oh you're right I don't know what's over
here does it like anything so we'll go
through here yeah I guess I could open
up say try opening the case that thing
yeah see what happens
oh this is new yes
what is that an elevator going up it
looks like her not cool
oh my god sanitization sanitizing thing
I don't like it oh it's so on [ __ ] why
is it green I can't pick any of this
[ __ ] up
I got rounds you can't yeah where's the
storage units when you need them this is
cool I know could combine the two greens
is that what we want like you haven't
been poisoned in a while now there you
go
okay okay what is that though oh sweet
he's gone yes yes let's think about this
okay which wait we don't know I don't
know that yeah I don't like [ __ ] it out
what you could ruin it just back out I
can't go no go back to 100 what it was
100 now press the button yeah yeah
okay there's gotta be oh there's another
urban from the computer there - that is
the same era but I didn't pick it up oh
there's a red that's worth picking up oh
yeah and convinced damn I wish we knew
that you would just like if you're gonna
be poison cuz then you could just
combine that I think ribbons are really
what's [ __ ] you up I know I regret
doing it I regret I regret I said I
regretted it and I don't want to talk
about it anymore
I deal there shotgun shells in the table
as well it looks like I can't pick those
up like that's not worth using my own
double check that those are shotgun
shells I think they are right
yeah I don't yeah that sucks because
you're only using the shotgun down here
maybe that's gonna be useful for when
you open the capsule so maybe you should
take those I have no items how do I find
out the temperature setting no it's just
a part we haven't gotten to yet it's
gotta be waiting in this room there's
the fridge this is where I'm gonna find
the liquid because it'll turn blue when
I get it to a certain temperature and
they said the temp the temperature was
the date oh wait there's a note about
this let's open that we read it oh I
didn't know that was that boring jargony
one and I remember what these mean go
down through it the yellow one maybe
letters do you import it was called no
the workers diary I can always look it
up try the bottom one the workers report
the workers Diaries the guy who was mad
because he like never got his
compensations it's not that guy alloy a
report member so it was saying like it
makes you immune to acid but you have to
but it's under inclement stigma
yes it's called funky II
[Music]
okay a is used for gun maintenance and
possesses no conspicuous characteristics
but funky e changes its color to blue at
a certain temperature
it's odd coincidence that the
temperature is exactly the time as the
date of completion of this training
facility that's gotta be in the note
somewhere should I look that up or you
feel like browsing through it I'll look
it up or just look maybe like flip
through and see it could be in like
all right
what if it is on the guy who was like
annoyed you fine newspaper maybe
newspaper Clinton I'm gonna read the
workers diary hate this place
alright so I found it but I don't know
if you want to find it on your own what
can you tell me a hint
is it a note is it I have no answer
oh that's not nearly no that's what I'm
trying to I'll go like to a walkthrough
that actually tells you I just found the
date mmm owed a new master confession to
be any of these
[Music]
Oh one episode on this the day you
eventually have to combine that with
Clement a and then put that on the Eagle
thing which that said great I don't
think it's any of those so I think it's
one of these this fax could hold the
info oh wait is that I think it's the
anniversary of Pearl Harbor today no the
date your no today's d-day Oh different
the the date you're looking for is do
you know I think
you're welcome Bhaiji
I have no idea hey what the [ __ ] I got
this I think it's I'm just looking for a
number take it easy mr. Calus all right
I'm getting all right so sorry for clip
don't eat don't look that's the alloy
all right now [ __ ] now
tray honks report
[Music]
it's you might as well just do it it's
1:28 like December 8th
but 128 is not December 8 you mean 1208
128 128 degrees because that was what
you had to do wouldn't that be the 28th
of January I'm just saying like 128
degrees because you have three numbers
to work with
and it's 12/8
[Music]
what yeah turn blue
is it gonna be the yellow one
okay so I took it and now I can't take
anything else in here okay
[Music]
I want a storage box and I want to save
I'm really uncomfortable I would go to
the safer actually no yeah okay so kind
of jog your memory all right
oh wait I'm in the wrong spot let's try
this again
[Music]
and I don't remember like where the
closest one is feel like I'm really okay
I keep getting like really turn around
here in here yeah okay just look like a
wall this is where that capsule was yes
you know 'pn this actually I don't know
if you can yet you tried
I can't I don't even know I've got dad
he call him on it from the front maybe
it's just something you do later I don't
know there's a lot of questions a lot of
questions they've lowered the other one
too on the right side okay let's
remember that's there okay that's good
though and that's also good that didn't
there's a lot of stuff in this area I
need to like what's save room are you
closed
oh okay so this area sucks so scary okay
so yeah you can go I think we didn't go
into the water yet
no we did not which we should I don't
know if we should yeah we should
don't put the shotgun back though yeah
so now I think you can go into the water
Oh God oh my god
I can't pick up whatever's in the water
well that's not that's a zombie
yeah they get sneaky nice
yeah just lump it up
simple mcdhh imple
oh my god he drowned okay he did um on
the left
I'm sorry see I'm going here at all if I
can't pick up anything I think there's
another way up where you can keep a [ __ ]
yeah god I hope it's a save room
they'll be so cool be very convenient oh
that was the manhole earlier okay I know
where I am
oh there's a save room right around the
corner yes sweet that honestly might be
once we get there in episode we're gonna
show the fan art as well it's been
almost an hour well do you think I'm
safe should I put things away yeah yeah
and like collect them now no I know what
triggers the next thing and I can we can
avoid it okay you already have save
pucks in your inventory right now oh
yeah
kinda more like make a post-it notes IOP
need to collect and everything we need
to collect there's so much stuff that
we've to read herbs an assault rifle
clip and a green herb shotgun shells
grenade rounds grenade rounds that
doorknob thing that was on the ground so
whatever was on top of that box not sure
how you get those are you saved yeah
okay wait hold on I'm gonna switch to
the camera and okay sweet I just want to
pull out that stuff and I emailed it to
myself so once we get this yeah oh
there's gonna be no music for a second
what are you
I already a.m.
Mary's gonna try to figure this out
no no no wait no
when I came in here I just unplugged the
HDMI from the PC and put in the ps4 you
should be good just plugging that into
the graphics card and you should be fine
sorry about the lack of music I am I'm
singing the song so how's everyone doing
nobody sweet we could switch seats so I
can pull up my email as that might be
asleep we're going through all this
trouble to show fanarts worth it I pull
on switch I think how is everybody well
I guess you kind of have to that was
[Laughter]
switch seats yeah oh wait you know it's
funny about this just hang out guys hi
I'm hi I'm Mary yeah I'm wearing my
sweater it's all this is all the part of
the plan oh I see what you did thought
of if it's the gnarly collar there's no
internet oh you saved right you saved
oh um plug to the Internet we do this
because we love you hope you guys are
excited about III it's like when this
gets released it'll be the next day so
it's a very exciting time yeah it's
tomorrow it's so busy here we go
I'm gonna take these down
so that we can well actually I'm gonna
change into the thing when you're ready
I'm fat and I'm stretching out your
sweater I don't know damn it okay I'll
figure it out hold on haha this is a
process yeah how's twitch III planning
coming along it's a nightmare
it's very rewarding but super exhausting
rewarding nightmare it's a rewarding
nightmare it's so tiring I'm proud of it
but my goodness okay I don't want people
to see Maya so open up all your links
and then close it oh yeah that makes
sense
well this is a sensitive Mouse and one
more I feel weird in this sweater okay
all right cool okay so here's a people
if you remember that joke from when this
bozo forgot the fire extinguisher time
you Benedict
thank you never forget your Photoshop
this is from Jamie circus he uh
personified the fire extinguisher said
he was doodling while he was uh yeah
you get the gist can we like just
appreciate his like the kool-aid man
BTUs in his hands yes it's good and then
here is Jonathan chance another person
who's been that was the same one as
before no it's it's different similar
they did they took the same fire singer
I think plagiarism not kidding yeah
chance has been watching the show sweet
so yeah I thought there was the one that
had us on it oh that would take me a
while to find someone compared me to
Leon marry to Claire that was also Jamie
circus I believe I want that one I want
to pull that next time because no my
notifications are
I saw it when you were looking through
yeah but I'm not signing the Twitter on
this computer these are just links I
mean Michael hyams Twitter account just
do it
you want me to do it right now okay I
got out sign out of this why does every
sees if it's Jonathan
maybe you could find it that way oh I
see what you're saying no it's more
convenient they're so good
I wouldn't be under here would it be
under thanks for bearing with us we love
when you guys send us this stuff it
makes us happy no no it thinks you're
creating again there's some really good
stuff going on behind the scenes here
you need to go back out you need to go
into login you've like lost yourself oh
here we go yes here we go what's my
password I think that's it okay sweet
sweet sweet sweet you've done it here we
go okay this one's my favorite barely
lianna's Kennedy Bandersnatch as Bandar
snooch and there's big fire extinguisher
on every cent worth it and Mary Kay yeah
there is it's called you mary-kate
mary-kate and Ashley Olsen as Jill
Valentine thanks Jamie
that's is it look at my sick packs I did
give you some packs gave me some - all
right well there's that damn band or
sneezes cracked head veins oh all right
all right well sweet well I guess that's
pretty much it I think so so after III
have fun uh watching III guys and we'll
be back the next week famous oh the week
after
yeah well probably not we won't publish
a week from today or tomorrow right yeah
it'll be
during e3 so we can't but we'll be back
the week after two weeks from now we'll
see you well enjoy three and we'll see
you the next week love you this sweater
is so hot like like temperature-wise
yes I know it's definitely not the other